hello and welcome to this video play I
am surfer rosa all Rico ball Argentina
is a sound very Latin American name okay
this is a possible way to play we'll
have six that always felt a little bit
too ugly from you and I studied it but
it might not be all that clear why does
basically now making a gambit out of it
one note is contemplating here not
taking must be very weird or I see what
what is the idea here how can you not
take in this pollution okay maybe a six
first or something like that's possible
what does it it doesn't make much sense
to be able to be honest okay this is
possible and play for d5 young this is
possible especially considering that my
bishop is on f4 so if i take night eggs
as a temple and then bishop
so the f6 having played f6 is extremely
ugly
hmm
I wonder about this if i take if i do
this if that Bishop a 3m should take
screen takes Knight g4 25 texts ISA b5
room it's a whole bunch of trades
but okay I can do this right that
shouldn't be bad or it goes back okay I
was thinking that that cake sticks it
must be a very decent compensation in
fact after takes takes Knight takes d4 I
can take be seven or if he takes him I
take with green projects sorry um c7 was
hanging yeah he goes for f4 so I'm going
to play why cannot play we should be
five wow I had a blackout him complete
blackout
okay I have a funky idea 24 24 Bishop
takes Knight takes and now he has a for
him that doesn't work 94 bishop d 196
rights too wacky 94 Bishop t1 group d1f
496 if i get there for porn or not lose
my bishop this is actually viable but it
doesn't work
maybe the test work actually at 496 how
does he prevent that for me not ok if it
doesn't work what if what the heck the
key thing is f4f 496 I think this should
should be playable they don't lose this
Bishop then this is this interesting as
he 6 and section enormous square I still
think it probably should play it ok
maybe it takes no takes on default takes
Queen to f6 that could be an issue
that could be at home I don't see a good
reply to this ad e-m-f 496 that that
should be okay actually I should get
there for porn and then this is this is
fine and 496 queen d 6 is Bishop age for
as well I can also take the rook maybe
but if you take SOG d for Luke cakes and
then queen to f6 ok I can actually just
have look T 1 i'm a bit slow today that
that feels ok he's taking a long while
now maybe this is not objectively
correct but in a in a blitz game that
feels kind of viable and threatening a
lot here so he decided to do this so
here I was thinking Queen d6 but I even
have night b5 and stuff like that night
b5 queen before ok and Bishop h4 is the
kind of reserved move not ideal night
before the screen to see if I if that
doesn't do much 95 ok I can also take f8
but after you take g3 that night has no
square so let's go here
it's not brilliant that the bishop has
to go here but you know if I cannot take
let's take him and now reroute it to
deform this is going to be okay no it
take back or Kleist it take back are you
serious in a five-minute pool okay maybe
I mean I did ok I just want to prove
that this is okay anyway take back
accept it take back accept it normally I
don't do that right there this position
is okay for white anyway so let's see
check time warning check okay look on
the F file also was quite good check
check
it's not actually a legal move it should
have taken the Queen ER check that would
have been much easier black resigned
yeah it was really okay I mean I didn't
need a mouse lip to to have a good
position down so interesting very
interesting situation like f5d 594 so
this is the critical line again I'm not
sure that it objectively works I rather
doubt that but in a blitz game let's see
what what the computer makes out of it
so i take it takes computer wants to
play 96 and it is also possible but i
felt this should be okay so what now the
computer wants to take and play rupee
aid hmm i did not really appreciate
rookie aid but i was thinking you know
he has an extremely open King just a
bishop on the long diagonal is end of
game but maybe I don't get down let's
it's possible of course computer has
looped d2 d1 why would you do that why
not this immediately okay the Queen here
and now I cannot do this because of the
capture some the hook is a little bit
vulnerable on that square and doe came
ok and I said the computer probably will
show that it is not objectively working
I don't get to that diagonal I mean it
just transfer the bishop here and black
is in big trouble but i probably don't
get down so this maybe is standard the
big issue with it so here
yeah things I am very very unclear nitey
end this was a simple approach okay
night c4 is in is a very interesting I
didn't see that of course trying to get
this in and if I take a check a check
yeah bits with you I mean this is
getting interesting the night comes to
you form you probably he has to give
away in exchange anyway so I'm taking
this now hear that the engine is on
roughly equal but this is easier for
white to play I have the initiative the
channel called fam do yet no time you've
learned at this and now I should have
taken the Queen check up to write the
check was it [ __ ] did too hasty them
okay now it is a time scramble where I
was destined to win on time and
interesting though I think I always
rejected f6 because it just looks too
dumb damn ugly this the spectacles a
playable position yeah definitely I
wonder maybe maybe i should actually
delay this caption look at this now in
many this is a bit more precise so that
I have but we get you almost the same
kind of position very similar this isn't
so bad huh probably this is an idea home
difficult ok guys thanks for watching